david so far we've traced out a whole
lot of diff
strings threads in Mark's Gospel one of
these chief ones is this ongoing
question of who Jesus here and we get to
a config niture posing of that question
in Chapter eight what do you think is
going on as Jesus turns to the disciples
and ask this first question I I'm of two
minds on that and I'll give them both to
you that what Jesus asked is first of
all who do people say that I am and then
they give a list Elijah John the Baptist
we revived one of the prophets and then
he says to them who do you say that I am
and Peter picks it up and says you're
the Christ the standard answer which
most days I believe is that this is
Jesus testing them to see how far their
faith has come and we have certainly
been concerned all the way along with
saying are the disciples getting it or
are they not getting it and on that
assumption jesus knows the right answer
and is simply checking with the
disciples to see how well they're doing
with it the the more out there line is
that that we read Mark's Gospel as if it
were all decided from the beginning but
that in fact if you're read mark there's
a kind of progression in what Jesus says
about himself too and that this may be
the moment at which Jesus is firming up
in his own ministry who he's supposed to
be and so he asks about people and then
he asked about the disciples not just
for their sake but for his sake as well
I'm torn on that I find the second one
in some ways more appealing as drama the
first are probably more plausible as
exegesis as reading of the text but I
think what what's not in dispute is that
Peter gives an answer which which Jesus
we see is oddly ambivalently matthew i
believe and i know you do to use mark's
gospel and then reinterprets it for his
own time and it's just the same point in
Matthew's Gospel Jesus asked who do you
say that I am Peter says you are the
Messiah the Son of the Living God and
Jesus says blessed are You Simon son of
Jonah flesh and blood have not revealed
this to you but my Heavenly Father
you're the rock on this rock I'll build
my church Mazel Tov beautifully done
hooray Peter once again you've got it
and in Mark's Gospel Jesus just doesn't
say a mumblin word as you are the Christ
and then Jesus in some ways seems to
shift the topic and says the Son of Man
which is another title for himself it's
going to have to suffer many things
Peter doesn't say thank you very much
for clarifying who you are Lord and
Savior he says god forbid Jesus don't do
that he rebukes him and now Jesus turned
and rebuked Peter and says get behind me
Satan so there's a there's a there is
within the text of Mark I think
attention about one who Jesus is and to
what it means to say who Jesus is and
mark wants to say from 11 on that Jesus
is the Messiah but I think from 11 on
and certainly here he's saying not the
Messiah you were all expecting and
certainly not the Messiah that you Peter
were expecting and and the way I read
the texting and I love your help with
this the way I read the text is that
that that Jesus qualifies what Peter
says because at some level jesus knows
that what Peter means by that is not
sufficient meaning right that that what
it means for Jesus to be Messiah is what
who will suffer for us and will suffer
as God's representative and when Peter
says you're the Messiah he means Jesus
Christ Superstar you're you're on your
way triumph glory power and Jesus
answers that by saying let me let me
reframe the thing let's not even talk
Messiah language let's talk son of man
language let's talk suffering language
I'm not exactly the Messiah you want me
to be and then and then I think Peter
rebukes him for two reasons and this
will lead to some things we're going to
be concerned about I think later our
discussion he rebukes him partly because
he doesn't want this to happen to Jesus
I didn't he whoever peter is there's no
question he loves Jesus and His gospel
he may misunderstand him he will soon
enough deny him he will alas desert him
but he loves him I think that that's
never up for question in this gospel and
if you said to me all right Day After
Tomorrow here's the bad news I'm going
to die I would not be pleased right
because of my loyalty to you and that's
part of what's going on here but if you
said to me the following the day after
tomorrow
sure that those who are engaged in the
yale bible study will be executed
starting with me i would be doubly
displeased if this please first of all
because there you go and second of all
because there I go exactly and I think
at some level Peter says all right this
is the guy we're following if he's
saying here's my destiny my destiny is I
will be persecuted I will suffer many
things and I will die but he says well
if that's the deal for you what's the
deal for me and the god forbid becomes I
don't want that to happen to you and I
don't want that happen to me now but I'd
love your response on that I want to
come back to the Satan thing I mean yeah
I it occurs to me we haven't talked yet
about the way these different titles
right together already saw son of God in
chapter one twice while and then we've
seen Messiah here we've seen son of man
here and it has always seemed to me that
that this author has to use the
materials that are available to him
almost like the pallet doesn't come up
with new new names for Jesus but he
moves them it doesn't say that the the
metaphor I think of his he's got certain
paints on his palette yeah and he uses
those but he blends them and brings them
together differently and has been done
and in other Gospels in Matthew we we
see that done a little bit through John
the Baptist when John the Baptist asks
are you are you the one who is to come
or should we keep on looking right
because the expectation has been not
exactly met right exactly in this gospel
we get it in this episode exactly and
the way the the disciples don't until
the end so so yes I I think that's a
it's a good sort of pairing to look at
both the way the titles are brought
together and to look at what are the
motivations for Peter's office of
Sheriff Frank the Jesus comes back then
of course with if anyone wishes to
follow me yeah when wishes to come after
me let him deny himself take up his
cross and follow me which gets to one of
peter stage yes to one of Peters in and
and and I suspect Peter sees that one
coming I'm in a way Jesus says I know
what yeah in a way he's saying I know
what you're worried about and by god
you're right to be worried yeah that is
the deal Peter right right that if you
follow me
you're going to you to this is not just
my cross this is your cross the on the
Satan thing and then I wanted to pick up
the cross thing again when Jesus trenza
when says get behind me you Satan for
years I thought that was just a kind of
useful put down I know you dummy or you
unfaithful person or you about to deny
me guy but Satan in in the world in
which they lived and indeed in the world
of the other Gospels Satan is not just
the person who's wrong Satan's the one
who sets up the temptation sets up the
test and my suspicion is as I read mark
more and more often that when Jesus says
to him get behind me you Satan that's to
signal to us who are careful readers or
hearers that that's a real temptation
for Jesus right in Mark's Gospel we
don't have the temptation in the
wilderness but in many ways the
temptation the wilderness in Matthew and
Luke does the same thing give this all
up come home don't worry about this
don't worry about your power is just
going to get you in trouble Peter
becomes become Satan for that moment in
this text and he puts out the test for
Jesus and Jesus passes it by saying get
behind me get away from me but I think
it's a real temptation and I think it's
picked up in the garden and it's picked
up in the girl right when when Jesus
says can we do this any other way out
right exactly if it is possible let this
cup pass from go nevertheless not as I
will but as you will he's Rianne suring
exactly this temptation exactly exactly
and when Nikos Kazantzakis writes his
book called The Last Temptation of
Christ it's highly imaginative and
highly original but it really picks up
on a theme that really is there in the
Gospels which is the time after time the
biggest test for Jesus is to back down
that that and then he can seduce hasn't
marrying mary magdalene and all that we
don't get any of that but we do get that
idea that why don't we just go home why
don't we just back down why don't we not
suffer all these things yeah and for the
first time in the book here really we're
getting the shape of what it is to
follow Jesus we are right we've had
seven chapters of fantastic happenings
and some conflicts and ways that Jesus
has thrown data out there as to who he
is we then get this
quick run on who he actually is and a
turn to what it is to follow here that's
going to be coming up for a while we do
it right it's gonna it's going to keep
happening and in those in those passages
after what comes immediately after the
scene we just said which is the
Transfiguration he takes three with him
yeah right and says follow and come up
yeah talk to me about the
Transfiguration the Transfiguration is
in some ways for me what are the two
most puzzling texts in Mark's Gospel the
other one being chapter 13 that we'll
talk about soon because to be sure in
Mark's Gospel Jesus is extraordinary and
performed extraordinary miracles and the
Spirit comes down upon him but he's
transfigured in the Transfiguration
right I've Sesame just to be extremely
naive about it I suspect you that the
general radiance quality of Jesus up
until chapter 9 was he was about as
radiant as you are now which is not bad
but not stunning right i mean i don't
say whoa when you get to the
Transfiguration that as I was like whoa
Jesus because there he is shining
brightly absolutely glorious and
chatting with Moses and Elijah who are
these two great figures I we need to
pause I think on Moses and Elijah I've
read I've read different readings of
this but the simplest and I think to me
the most helpful still is that that one
way that Jewish people talked about
their Scripture was to say it's the law
of the prophets and had the law is
obviously Moses and for Judaism the
great prophet was always Elijah he was
the exemplary profit so in some ways
what you have is Joe is Jesus talking
with the law of the prophets as at
minimally and equal so here these
disciples have been trying to figure out
who is this guy is he the Messiah next
big moment is whoa not only easy sort of
the Messiah and sort of us on a man he
is suddenly chatting with Elijah and
Moses which is he goes to Mount Rushmore
do not pass go go straight to Mount
Rushmore and and
and then astonishingly at the next move
in the story and God basically says okay
now stop paying any attention to Moses
and Elijah this is my son this is the
one I want you to hear this is the
really big boy I I just have no idea
what the news weaker Time magazine
photographer would have seen if they'd
been one their theological e i think
what Mark is saying at this point is is
to kind of take its to take what what
Peter says and go even farther say oh
Christ thing is good enough we can beat
that this is not even just Messiah this
is not even just King like David this is
says God my own son so important that
when you got him plus the law plus the
prophets he's more important than either
the law the prophets listen to him right
right and you know the the radiance
issue there's that great scene in life
of brian where the the Wiseman come from
afar and they come to brians house as
he's a newborn and his mom is rude and
they come in and they can't figure out
quite what's going on but they're here
to give gifts to the babe and they they
lay the gifts of at the feet of this
child and they go out and in the next
house over is this bright light right
and then they come back in and their
gifts and they take out it would be so
much easier if it were just radiant so
exact radius all the time but the
radiance now I think has a purpose
because what he's just said is this is a
lot different than you thought that's
right he's just said this Messiah is a
dying one and so are you dying following
us and so maybe the the premium on
getting an audience here from the
disciples is the highest it gets in the
book all right yeah so we need we need a
highlighter way to our divine
highlighter pen here so God gives them
the highlighter pen and he says even
even against the things that made you
expect otherwise yeah listen to this
listen for this car he just also says
after this that they're not or mark says
they won't get this till after the
resurrection and I think in what part of
what Mark is saying to us as believers
is that the fullness of who Jesus is a
son of God is revealed not just through
his ministry not even through his
crucifixion alone right reveal in both
of those but not
exclusively finally in the resurrected
Christ we begin to see that this is not
only Messiah not only Son of Man but
God's own son and they will not get it
till they and they will not get it
that's in that point I want to circle
back for a minute to the line he gives
to Peter on to Peter and rest of the
disciples and then picks up again later
in this in this central chapter central
chapters of the gospel where he talks
about taking up our own cross and being
servants so often in our kind of pop
chat about things I'll say like well
I've got a grade 35 papers this week
that's just my cross to bear right right
which just heart-rending I mean you're
right go to buy comfortable home and
after a good dinner I sit down with nice
music on the CD player and grade papers
and by god that's my cross to bear when
Jesus says take up your cross and follow
me he doesn't mean grade 35 papers or
cut back on your ear on your cholesterol
for the next two weeks or put up with it
your difficult in laws for the holidays
those are not the crosses we bear those
are just annoyances he is speaking to a
world where to follow Jesus is to take
on the risk of losing everything for his
sake and for the sake of the gospel and
so that when when Peter hears that word
take up your cross and follow me he
doesn't think oh darn it's going to be a
hard week he thinks this may be
everything this may this may be the cost
of discipleship right and so Bonhoeffer
may be the place to end Jesus bids us to
come and die yeah right exactly that's
our time thank you